uh yeah guys keep a lookout for whenever
we do end up covering it going to be
honest y'all if i'm able to go watch
this in the theaters this week
that's how we're going to watch it
what's going on reject nation greg and
john here
today we are going to watch godzilla
cinemark theaters in l.a are open
again my mask is falling off it's
important that you keep your mask on
yeah you understand keep it on
you got to obey the rules here if you
want to enjoy the big screen but john
tell how it works all right well
basically because
things are slowly opening up cinemark is
offering private screenings so for 99
you can come screen yourself and up to
20 people a classic film or for 149 you
can screen
a new release like freaking godzilla
versus code so you can book this
instantly online through the website
you could bring up to 20 guests at least
as a matter of fact we just take a
preview inside of our friends really
quick
there's these two you might recognize
them they're famous in india this is a
private screening room these are all my
friends
he pays us well you can be as loud as
you want because it's your own private
screening room so
screw everyone but i swear to god if all
you guys
talk during this movie i'm gonna throw a
[ __ ] fit do you understand
shut up wow we can talk like that here
that's how you promote cinemark
come and be rude at the moment
none of them are abused by our behavior
right now all right so after this movie
we are going to give our quick review on
it but i'm just so happy we get to see
it in the theater because
godzilla versus calm i can't believe
we're back here it's so exciting
all right guys let's do it
all right before our opinion we're gonna
go around the group little by little
everyone's kind of nervous right now the
camera's on me guys
everyone's really tense right now
everyone's really tense everyone's po
what'd you think what'd you think no
spoilers i really liked it i think you
know we all came to see
titan's fight and it happened and it was
great i liked it a lot i did not like
the human element but the monsters were
a lot of fun the cinemark experience was
pretty damn cool daniel this is daniel
melgar hi hi i knew when he was a baby
i was i i didn't really know what to
expect coming in i should have even
though it's godzilla but i thought it
was great
awesome hey uh yeah like
jaby said i think the human element was
the biggest part where were three movies
in so what do you expect the monsters
what's cool yo i walked in as a godzilla
fan and i entered like i exited that
movie like donkey kong all the way i
disagree with everyone we all came to
watch humans interacting with each other
okay it was a lot of fun the action
sequence is really cool and there was
actually a really good emotional touch
between uh a certain titan and another
character in it that i really enjoyed so
where's really spoiler free
yeah it was a big old dumb fun uh got
exactly what i expected
uh monsters gonna be monsters man that
was the devastation of uh hong kong and
the worst uh tragedy for them okay
your opinion matters the most fantastic
that's all you gotta say right there
that's all i gotta say uh it was a ton
of fun
after i got to just see it and stay
tuned it was crazy fun but i would have
to
you have to watch it in theaters don't
watch it on hbo max you got to hear it
loud and see all of the beautiful
animation
it was very loud a lot of destruction
super fun it made me cry
but i really liked it it was a lot of
fun oh hanging on the heart thank you
guys
all right now that we got all their
opinions variety out of the way this
movie
was almost exactly what i wanted it to
be i don't want to spoil anything but in
terms of going in a theater experience
it was a hundred percent worth
it i mean that sincerely you see the
trailers you know this is the way to
watch the movie this is made for this
experience
and the finale hey this movie was a lot
more
bonkers weird it's got a real snappy
rhythm about it and it takes like the
other previous movies have some fun bone
crunching monster action but this one
really dialed up the attitude on it just
the right amount to where it's got a
little bit more fun for the intensity
without falling directly into like oh
it's a little too much yeah
there's a couple of humans i liked i
like the little girl i kind of liked
alexander skarsgard i think usually like
brian tyree henry
i got a kick out of him and uh the kid
from wilder people
but for the most part the humans were
pretty boring
but the godzilla kong movie you know the
humans aren't
what you're here for although they
didn't aggravate me as much as previous
films so i'll give it that i don't know
i thought the humans were a little bit
more the most boring they've ever been
but the movie itself was just so bizarre
and strange the thing i showed up for
was awesome and i think a lot of people
thought that the trailers ruined
too much and everything there were a lot
of things that are not in the trailers
there's a lot that's not in the trailers
that was really visually great to look
at
and a lot of surprises you'll get to a
point where you're like oh damn
i where i'm out of trailer footage now i
don't know what to expect
but yeah exactly yeah give me everything
i wanted pretty much oh yeah if you're
here for a kaiju movie you're gonna get
what you want
i thought even though the humans sucked
the thing you showed up for especially
that finale
we were all cheering especially in a
private room you could actually really
cheer and you won't feel like you're
disrupting people
yeah and i actually this is a weird
thing to say but i actually cared about
the you know kang and godzilla and their
relation
to the fight not just that they were
fighting and that it was cool
sure no sense whereas king of the
monsters i was just like fight do cool
stuff whereas this one i actually
actually cared about both i think
they've actually made kong
rather human like they're he gave him a
lot of depth and humanity i felt like
they gave a lot of that to kong i really
cared about i felt
feel pretty bad because i've been team
godzilla since day one but i felt
like i watched that i really care for
him happy everyone who played had a good
time yeah
if you're able to go into like a cinema
in a private room go to a theater
it's absolutely the best way to watch it
because yeah everything you want from
the trailers it delivers and there were
plenty of surprises
this was the way to watch it in theaters
for sure absolutely not just saying that
because we got
we got offered to do this it's the way
to do it it's the way to watch it thank
you cinemark
nwb what's up guys so we just got back
from the movie theater this is like
the first time in a long time we've been
to the movie theater and we got friends
there and then we're just like okay
let's just give her instant thoughts so
everything's just working off of like
our final moments and the exact feeling
so everything we said there was
you know we absolutely meant it but i
was like we should probably elaborate a
little bit more
you know had some time to take it in
after a 45-minute car ride
talked about some things in the car ride
and we have to film some other stuff but
before we go and film the other stuff i
was like let's just sit down
and chat with the audience about our
feelings on this after thinking about it
a little bit more
i mean i gotta say yeah the movie is
[ __ ]
really interesting it's like so
entertaining
for sure because the weirdly conflicted
feeling i was having on the car ride
back was
why am i so forgiving on the human
character sucking this time around
whereas like
the other ones that seem to be such a
detriment for me and i think it's
because
the filmmakers this time around knew
the humans sucked no one likes them no
one really cares about them that's not
what people are showing up here for
so let's just get the necessities out of
the way
for whatever we got to establish about
them to get an abc plot moving forward
so we can
mix it in with some great kaiju action
throughout i think that's the main
thing that was different about why it's
easier to be forgiving with the human
character sucking because this is like a
really expensive wonderfully
shot visually realized b movie
you know it has some like fantasy
elements there are elements that even
reminded me of like old ray harry
housing
things with the colors and the creatures
they bring and don't want to spoil too
much but if you've seen the trailers
those were really
well realized and really gorgeous to
like really dazzling i think that's an
element i wasn't expecting is like you
know you're gonna get kangen godzilla
destroying buildings destroying
familiar looking stuff but there's an
element yeah fantasy
and tone to this movie that the previous
couple haven't necessarily had
the human characters i gotta say i think
what the key to them sucking less this
time is like
you go back to king of the monsters i
thought those characters were actually
tedious to spend time with whereas here
yeah they're not
too caught up on making us care too much
or making that seem
yeah too dire or anything like that they
know they're not making a drama and so
the characters on the human side are all
over the place but there
are some fun shades and especially
through kong like we've seen in those tv
spots there is some actual
not gravitas is probably the wrong word
some tone that is
uh endearing and kind of melancholy to
get latched into so there's also sort of
that wonder that almost made me think
back to like mothra those moments in
king of the monsters that have that sort
of like awe struck
quality for the kaiju as well as all the
bone and building crunching you know
exactly i mean i think the little girl
does a really great job in here i mean
like that was my fa
in terms of the human aspect in terms of
character scenes
you it allows you to really make kong a
character in this film all right guys
while i'm slicing and dicing this i
gotta just interrupt really quick to
mention something i forgot to mention
which was millie bobby brown brian tyree
henry
and whoever the kid is that plays
russell and deadpool 2 that's in this
movie now
their plotline was
so boring it's been a long time
since i've seen a movie where so much of
the film i found myself
quoting ryan george saying super easy
barely an inconvenience
as they walk through what i call the
hall of expositions
yes the human characters for the most
part not that great in here but the part
that actually was like okay this is
really boring was when we would kind of
check in with those characters but still
it's a damn good time i think one part
that kind of
it feels a little bit left out for me
they didn't really take opportunity to
make godzilla
a character here he's kind of just here
in like the action scenes
he's over it he's frustrated you know
because he's taking on the you know the
why is he attacking role the villainous
side with kong though he's like the main
character of this film
and i think in the l without spoiling
the film in the last half of this movie
is where
most of the surprises really came into
play i think when you see like the
trailers you might feel like you've seen
too much or everything and you really
haven't in the last half especially
that's where a lot of what john was
talking about
with these like beautiful moments and
really just getting to
spend time with kong and some other
titans as well it really
helps build out the monster verse world
that much more kong even though i'm not
team kong even though i wasn't rooney
for him with my friends and
before i may i declared my stance before
i ever saw this movie i really found i
cared about him still
like i cared about that if there's any
character i
cared about genuinely it was actually
kong so made for a conflicting
experience for me at times
yeah because that's the actual journey
in this movie and again like so much of
the tone that
is beautiful and exhilarating in the
movie comes through his character
and the little girl is great i feel like
brian tyree henry i think that's where
some people might be a little split on
it's because brian tyree henry uh
like i thought he was kind of annoying
at times i think you you really enjoyed
him actually and i feel like a lot of
people
like even with our group they were mixed
on him some people really enjoyed him
and some people really didn't i think
the actors are all
fine it's just like they're they are
like the dull part of it
yeah i mean if you find them fun you
find them fun but i i i kind of was like
let's just get to the fun stuff and i
think the fun stuff is really
in there throughout the fight scenes are
incredibly realized the visual effects
are dazzling there
it's the best fights that out of any of
the monsterverse movies the choreography
of them and there's some unique things
that they do in adam wingard's direction
on where he sometimes
chooses like to mount cameras yes the
visual effects look great
yet i think one can play with king of
the monsters was
how like there was so much weather
involved in so many shaky cam that times
you couldn't tell what was going on
and everything was clear there's
multiple fight scenes in this movie and
the fights just get
better and better and better and yes
there's a character
who a lot of people figured out from the
day the first trailer was released was
gonna be in here
if you don't know who that is i won't
say it i feel like at this point
everyone already does but when
that character's in here holy [ __ ]
that was incredible it was incredible
last half is when it just becomes like
oh this is this is the movie for the
monsters
you know yet the stakes were still felt
it knew what it was it just wanted to be
an entertaining flick and i'm glad we
saw it in theaters i think it's the best
way to experience it i think if you have
an opportunity to see in the theaters
do it at home try to at least watch it
with headphones on when you get one of
those things going if you can see
if you can set it up on a big tv if you
can get like bluetooth headphones for it
if you have a playstation plug it into
there
but if you can watch in the theaters do
it that's the best way to do it
undoubtedly this film delivered knows
what it is had a great time
you'll be a happy monster fan see you
reject nation